oh hey are you going a little stir-crazy
during quarantine
that's okay we've got some announcements
and ways that you can stay connected
we're casting for an upcoming series
called the leap we want to challenge you
to reconnect and reach out to someone it
could be a family member that you had a
falling-out with or even a friend that
you need ask for forgiveness if you're
interested please sign up in the link
below and just a reminder we have prom
coming up April 17 don't forget to RSVP
in the link down below and follow us on
Instagram for additional information
the invitation that God gives to the
people that he made is so so generous
and came at such a high price to try
seagate a dog and that he gave up a
weekend right
I am a Presbyterian pastor I'm a Hindu
I'm Muslim hi I'm Lois I'm a Satanist
to be honest when I heard of Satanist my
first reaction was something that is
that does not align with my core beliefs
I think of like a lot of darkness and
evil and and wasps nests when I think of
Abrahamic faiths
I think of slaughtering zand burnings
and mutilations all in the name of God
to myself I don't actually have a image
or a person or a thing that I think of
when I think of a and their record for a
stay in a shape on is what's whispering
in your ear in a sense of trying to lead
you away from God one of the things I
like about it personally is that they
are actively fighting to make sure that
every religion like has a chance to have
a say right now in this country I'm
approaching this with a spirit of
curiosity love to ask questions and and
and hear more about the perspectives and
the people that I'm going to be talking
to you and as for the major religions I
hope to understand why they stayed
within their religion if they were born
into it or I hope to understand how they
justify their beliefs
[Music]
my name is Sean Kendall I'm a
Presbyterian pastor married to my wife
Kelly and we have three children
I'm Armour ASA I'm 19 years old
I'm Muslim I was born raised in a Muslim
household muscle my whole life it's a
big part of who I am my name is Jason
Turgeon I'm 33 I am a Satanist
I was raised Christian and have somewhat
recently converted my name is Ragini I
was born and raised in India and then I
moved here for grad school and currently
I'm a director of jewbilee media and I'm
Hindu I'm Lois I'm 23 and I'm a Satanist
and I was raised Jewish my name is
Richard Lane I'm older than I like to
tell people I'm a Satanist
I was raised Christian but I am a
Satanist get my fakeness back there on
the left and members of major religions
on the right hell is a real place
I don't actually know like when I try to
think of what hell looks like to me I
don't think it's how it's been in movies
or people just talk about like I'm some
fiery inferno
I believe in an afterlife where there is
a kind of a good place in a bad place
where what you do here kind of
determines where you're gonna end up
yeah one of the signs that there is
something greater than us out there is
that we see something beautiful that we
want someone to express our Thanksgiving
to and our worship towards and in the
same way on the opposite end of the
spectrum when there are terrible deeds
or acts that are committed by humans
towards one another that there also
needs to be a place of of justice and so
I yeah I believe that
there is a heaven and that there is a
hell and that the gift of grace that God
offers us is so generous that for those
who reject it that there has to be a
place of judgment so yeah personally I
would never worship a God they would
send someone to an eternal lake of fire
to be burned forever for the simple fact
of non belief when that deity knows what
it would take to convince every single
person on this planet that is cruel it
is inhumane it is not kind it is not
generous and that is not a God worthy of
worship what's more it would be damning
all I mean the vast majority of everyone
who's ever existed for not believing in
him for a set of rules that he created
to be fair I feel like this presupposes
that to burn in hell means that you
don't believe in God I'm sure that there
are religions and I know that there are
people who believe that hell is a place
for murderers you know and when I was
Jewish we didn't believe in Hell they
didn't even talk about the devil I just
kind of came upon it myself I believe
that in the event that we have spirits
and they will go on to some other realm
it's probably more of a nebulous place
than a physical Hell lake fire
everything I don't even believe we have
souls necessarily I'd like to see some
evidence
that we're even conscious like I'm about
to have an existential crisis up here
the I think the historical Christian
position is is that the gift of the the
invitation that God gives to the people
that he made it so generous and came at
such a high price too high price he gave
a dog and that he gave up a weekend
right he was God before yeah yeah he was
gone during and he's God now he gave up
a weekend if I knew right now that I
could go off and die and then not die
how where's the gift in that number one
I'm able to look at the the grace that
has been extended to me and yeah and I
received it okay so the way that I would
commonly think of it is is that if I
gave up the life of my own son in
exchange for your life that is okay then
for me to to make the the invitation
that God makes towards us is that moral
is it moral is it moral Oh incorporeal
leather Jesus took on the penalty that I
deserved for the the sins that I
committed if we're looking at you know
the traditional Christian faith and so I
receive his gift of grace and as a
payment for the things that I had done
so your question is it moral or is it
just is it fair I'm able as a Christian
to say no it's not fair because I
deserved that the punishment that he
took on himself faith to me is
everything we grew up in a household of
faith and and and learned to love love
Jesus and love the church and serve the
church from the family that I grew up in
and so my wife and I have embraced that
same life of faith and we have taught
the Christian faith to our children to
understand themselves in their world
because of him and and and his and his
teaching
there's a higher purpose in life I mean
I think I strongly believe if there's a
higher purpose in life I don't think
I've found it yet and I hope I'm I would
like to believe that I will one day in
the journey of my life I completely
agree I don't I don't know what my
purpose is and I don't think it's
there's like a higher purpose that fits
for everybody but to me the note the
idea that there's some bigger purpose
has always been very comforting to me
otherwise kind of what's the point of
all this
no I fully agree I think that I believe
it's a question that we all ask and it's
one of the gifts of faith and in my in
my opinion so that when there's times of
epidemic and were pandemic pandemic
you're right that's a better worldwide
that that we're able to understand even
in those situations of difficulty and
conflict and and anxiety and fear that
there is a higher purpose in life and
that there's more than what we see I
trouble with the phraseology higher
purpose because that again that denotes
do I believe God no but I do believe
higher purpose as in love to give to be
generous to be kind to help to heal to
be there to understand the phrase higher
purposes it's alerted because it's like
God said yeah I choose you and you are
gonna do this thing and you're gonna
continue doing this thing for the rest
of your life and I really struggle with
that tonight can I just ask and I mean
this with all with because I received
your statement with that just curiosity
what if everyone was committed to this
idea that like in the way that you
expressed it so I would say when some
people that are sort of probe religion
like like I am would say that in order
for us to bind together as a culture and
learn to kind of work together and help
cause one another to flourish we have to
agree on
kind of higher purpose or a common set
of principles and I disagree I don't
really see a need for having a
prescriptive purpose I'm struggling to
even see what you see as the value in
saying that you have a higher purpose
maybe it's more of a fear or a concern
right that if everyone got up every day
and said that life is all about me and
and and that's what and I'm not
suggesting at all that that's what
you're saying about it is my belief I
don't mean to interrupt either no it is
my belief that one should take care of
oneself yeah yeah because nobody else
will yeah people who do take care of
themselves they understand that it is
balance and they're not going to go out
and and cause anarchy and mayhem in the
streets it can even be like a selfish
act to be helping the community around
you and it's still a good thing it's
still important it doesn't take a higher
purpose to make that kind of thing
happening I was going to school with the
intention to become an ordained minister
in the Pentecostal church one of the
things there is you read the Bible a lot
every day all day and after doing that
for like several hours a day and reading
the Bible through back to back several
times and discussing it I just I wasn't
sold at all I guess I style myself more
as in a skeptic and a humanist than
anything and Satanism just happens to
fit really nicely in that category for
me and this is actually also kind of
like my outing video like my family
doesn't know I'm a member of TST they
don't know I'm a Satanist I believe in
good and evil
[Music]
I haven't as part of my own belief
system for sure a conviction that all of
our hearts can at some times lead us to
do acts of evil and so so I see it in
the world around me but on both sides I
think the phrasing is something that's
it's a catchy stick out of here it just
so I believe in right and wrong and I
think some things for me a lot of things
lie in the gray area but there are some
things that I consider right and wrong
but I wouldn't say it's the same as good
and evil right that was beautifully set
that was but yeah no I agree with that
but I also believe that what is right
and wrong has changed throughout history
and it's it's something where I don't
know if everyday actions that I do right
now are going to be considered evil
later on like is driving a car gonna be
considered wrong I don't believe in an
evil entity who is you know pitchfork
and horns and looking like me with a
goatee that doesn't actually happen if
you ask anybody throughout history
they're always the hero of their own
novel mmm-hmm even yesterday I went at
the grocery store and there was one
person who had like more than 10 packs
of toilet paper at home and I do
understand that where the paper is not
gonna save you yeah I do understand that
he was like he's being cautious and
watching out for himself and his family
I just think the act of doing that is
wrong because there were so many people
who couldn't buy toilet paper to him
that was right
but that is he was looking out for his
family probably yeah it's like well like
I said like I'm saying that I think the
act is wrong but I wouldn't say that
he's evil like unless he has IDs or
something I don't know some of the core
beliefs of Hinduism is to believe in
karma
making sure that you have enough for
yourself and also enough for other
people but Satan in Hinduism is like an
assistant to God is someone who can
cause disruption but that is more - for
the benefit of human beings
lunch I believe Satan is evil I was
trying to play out in my head but then I
as I don't agree with that well the fact
that there is a Satan who is real and
the fact that he is evil as I mean it's
it's an important pretty central belief
that we hold in the Christian faith and
that there is a good and loving God and
a Satan who is evil so so let's go back
to Genesis okay God wanted to keep
humans from eating the fruit of
knowledge correct and Satan or the
serpent wanted to give humans that
knowledge I believe that's a good action
it is a good action that's a good action
that's justifiable the first person to
advocate for equal rights yes we only
heard God's perspective and for my purse
I mean just looking into the Bible it's
like we didn't hear Satan's perspective
maybe he said this is God as a
tyrannical God and I'm going to rebel
from him and I'm going to become a
fallen angel to help mankind my
interpretation and understanding of that
story is that God created an environment
where he in it was environment of love
and peace and and where his children
that he created and who he loved who he
created in His image with understanding
yeah yeah and that they would this is an
environment for them to to flourish and
so he puts them in this environment and
he desires for them to flourish and to
be and to live in in an unashamed
relationship with him in his perfection
and his glory and
and stupid I see God making simple
playthings because he's bored if it's
real then and then saying don't do this
because I don't want you on my level and
if you do I have to make sure you can't
live forever so you really don't get on
my level would you think that if you
heard that you're one of your friends
was having a baby and you'd say oh
you're just making a plaything for your
there are some that's how I see the same
generative love that out of which God
created us I think for me from as much
knowledge as I have about Satan
I think Satan is a symbol of freedom and
liberty right so that is not evil of
course like we discussed before if
people commit wrong deeds in the name of
Satan and that's wrong for me I was i
flip-flop a little only cuz I I don't
think that on his own
sayin is evil I think yes he's used to
represent evil whether he does or not
that's what he's useful his characters
very much used to say like you do
something wrong like oh that's an act of
like a devil kind of Satan represents to
me taking responsibility for your own
actions it says to thirst for knowledge
for understanding to understand that man
is an animal sometimes worse than those
around but an animal religion religion
has caused a lot of harm is is it the
ultimate source of evil no ultimately
people make their own decisions but we'd
talk about Crusades and witch trials and
the God hates [ __ ] and the and and the
snake handlers and the and and the the
Hitler situation of science the the
subjection of science the arts I mean I
don't know that there's been a major war
that hasn't been at least fuelled by
religion if not directly started by it
some of them were just political things
but they were always has a religious
backing at some point that like flared
the fire effin made it so much worse
than it would have been
and they vote I think religion dictates
moral values for a lot of people and the
way people interpret religion has caused
harm but religion itself would never can
never cause any harm it is meant for the
good of society and for the good of
people
I disagree with that yeah and like I
said it the way because I don't think
any God would say that okay this child
is gonna burn in hell it's probably the
way people have interpreted it or the
way people tell others the way they've
practiced someone some people have
practiced it there is harm in religion
done in the name of religion but it's
hard to quantify on a cost-benefit
analysis kind of way which is worse you
know having religion or not having
religion religion is a form of power it
is a tool and it reveals the worst in
humanity and it reveals the best of
humanity and you can do a lot in the
name of religion but you can also do a
lot of good in the name of religion yeah
I agree with that I think in the the
power word is very important to me I
have a lot of sensitivity about that and
and and where where Christians have used
either the Bible or or or their own
conviction to express authority over
other people in a way that doesn't lead
to their flourishing I think I think
we're in agreement on that as a member
of the Christian Church I would say that
there have been great contributions of
people of faith in to the the cause of
human flourishing and through medicine
and healthcare in the arts and education
and all those kinds of things so I
wouldn't go about for the arts and
medicines but the arts yeah not for the
money but the arts yes
Christian is amazing beautiful artwork
beautiful artwork I see those artists
you're not Christian I love it I love
seeing Sebastian portraits I love all
some of the choral music is beautiful
the tradition is sometimes beautiful
there's there's beautiful things in it
and it can help calm someone if that is
what they need I do believe that people
do need rituals I myself have rituals
but I mean I think really it has given a
lot of people some kind of peace of mind
and I think like even if it's
necessarily like I got I think I said
what to you like someone believed in God
like well that's not true why would you
do that
I guess to me believing in God I don't
think and I've never ever imposed my
religion on anyone around me I used
something like a personal relationship
between me and God and it just it's
helped me again lots of time and those
times alone like and those dark moments
I guess there in those happy moments
just thanking God for blessing my life
or in those dark moments like feeling a
little less alone is what it's helped
and I think I people I talk of like
those similar things in that respect
I've always been proud of my religion
it's never something I've tried to hide
I think it's like if someone would have
a conversation with me
not in an overbearing way but it would
be something that would come out very
quickly in the conversation for some
reason or another I consider myself a
good person I'm a great person
I really think good and bad is objective
because does everyone love me no there
are people who absolutely wish me dead
and that's okay I maybe I deserve it
from them I don't know but on the other
hand you know I help little old ladies
across the street and I I give to the
poor and I give time and energy and so
is that good maybe you're not weighs the
bad it's that constantly striving to be
better and whatever means that is moving
forward sense not just thing stagnant
and I'm this and I'm gonna say this way
all the time it's an active possibility
every single day no I do believe that
being good is in these minut like little
actions these micro actions that you do
every single day I'm intrigued
do you guys basic more on your
intentions are more on your actions
intention is really important because
sometimes you do something thinking that
it's going to be a good thing but it
turns out to be disastrous but as long
as you had a good intention in it I feel
like it's like who is certain except
yeah how many people do good things
because they think that's what people
expect good things to be yeah and for me
I would just hope that that my faith
would would be born out an acts of
kindness and mercy and compassion and
charity and and I know that that doesn't
necessarily come from me but I believe
that that that I'm a good person because
of who God has made me to be I think
you're a good person because you're a
good person I also think you're I think
you are more moral than the God of the
Bible I think you're a genuinely good
person and I think you're better than
the than the Bible I think there's good
in everybody maybe sometimes it's deep
deep deep but but I do think that at
their core everybody is a good person
well I'm a Satanist because I originally
started out as an atheist but I wanted
to find more ways to do advocacy work
within a separation of church and state
and also I think Satan is pretty cool
Satan is kind of a daddy so here I am
today
talking about Satan I respect all
religions respect all religions our spec
- if you're a good person and you're
doing you know if you think your
religion is great but I mean there's
probably a religion out there that I'm
gonna say that's not okay I'm saying I
respect all religions and sense of the
ones that I know of I guess some obscure
thing that I'm not aware of that really
does stand for horrible things I don't
agree with change yeah I think whatever
you want to store your faith in and if
it helps you helps you to unite with
other people of course I'm sure we all
respect that and that helps you lead
your life though I have committed my
life in in future to a religion that
believes that it is the right in the
only way you know I also believe I
respect people and and love people and
believe in people's freedom to to choose
even in Islam in the Quran we have this
one chapter what it talks about is the
respecting of other people's religions
like your religion is for you and my
religion is for me and like my religion
is behind on your religion as yours and
like that's okay in a sense we're
separate from each other but still
preaching that respect
for 100 like it's it's a platitude of
all religions to say I respect your
religion and I respect your religion I
respect your religion but you're all
saying oh I respect your right to have
that religion but then internally you're
saying Allah is the only God Jesus is
not God
Vishnu Krishna these are gods these are
deities Jesus Christ is the only way he
is the answer he is the only one I'm
right you're all wrong but I'm going to
be nice about it I think that there's a
difference between believing that
somebody else's religion is wrong and
respecting it I feel like you can have
respect and still disagree and that's
where I'm kind of coming from in I
disagree with all of you guys on your
religious beliefs but of course
everybody disagrees on their religious
beliefs I think we all disagree with
that each other to a certain extent but
we can all live in harmony and recall
I'm not as lessens views I mean I don't
really follow a specific organized
religion but I do believe that at my
core my belief system is full of love
for everybody and respect first tenet
and the Temple of Satan is to have
compassion and empathy for all living
creatures within a reasonable
understanding of it so I just love
yourself too I think that's important
for me as always
again that's why self-love agos was
always like preach self respect for
yourself respect your body respect your
belongings respect your public space
here respect the earth and love all and
it's it's just been a guiding force for
love in my life and I think it's because
of the love that's rooted inside within
it I'm curious did you learn anything
about the other side or about a specific
person in this group that you didn't
expect for me honestly it was more of
that I didn't know what to expect only
cuz I I mean I know a bit more about
Christianity I know a bit more about
Hinduism just that you don't learn about
Satanism in school very much to be fair
not to interrupt
we three identify a Satanist but we
three also believe very different
of course and I just I think that's why
for me I didn't really come in with many
expectations I was just willing and
eager to hear what you had to say here
your point of view our reason for doing
what we do is a bit different I think we
all want to be good people and live good
happy lives and preach love in some way
or another not as I don't mean preached
in religious I mean like be loving
people I think we all want similar
things just for different reasons
Satanism is a newer religion I mean the
Satanic temple obviously extremely new
yeah Church of Satan as run by Anton
LaVey it's very new Aleister Crowley
still within the last pretty new - I
mean obviously there's been occultism
throughout the world for ages and agents
agents but we have the benefit of coming
in with these progressive ideologies and
being able to form a new idea of what is
acceptable in light of the coronavirus
we are doing handshakes or hubs or
anything like that but in your own way
express affection to each other as a
group thank you oh yes that was a good
one that's a very good one
Elsie
[Music]